Imagine you go hiking in a desert canyon.
You see some rocks, some cacti, maybe some caves in the canyon sides.
What would you conclude is the best explanation for the features you saw before you?
Well, obviously you think that natural forces, wind, erosion, maybe water, were at
work.
But what if you went hiking into a desert canyon and this time carved into the walls
was an ancient city? Now, what would you conclude is the best
explanation?
There actually is a place like this.
It's the ancient city of Petra, which is found in the country of Jordan.
Now, when modern day explorers came across Petra, do you think they stopped and
thought, oh my goodness, this is the result of natural forces?
Of course not. When you look at Petra today, you can see intricately carved pillars,
buildings into the side of the solid rock.
You can see tombs and even a complex tunnel system for water.
So why do we recognize design in the city of Petra, but not in a typical canyon?
Well, Petra has a feature that we call specified complexity.
It might sound complex or daunting, but it's actually common sense and intuitive
when you think about it. If
something is specified, it has a particular pattern.
For example, take crystals.
Crystals are specified according to a certain pattern.
Shells are specified according to a pattern.
Even pulsars emit light at regular intervals.
But nobody looks at these and assumes design because they lack complexity.
They can easily be explained by the regular workings of the laws of nature.
When something is complex, it has multiple parts.
Take, for example, a pile of rocks.
Any pile of rocks is actually quite complex.
But we don't assume that a pile of rocks is designed because it lacks specified
complexity. So like a shell, like a crystal, like a pulsar that emits
light, we don't assume that a pile of rocks was designed.
Design requires both specificity and complexity.
You see, natural forces alone can result in things being specified with a pattern,
such as we see in crystals. Or natural forces can bring about things to be complex,
like a pile of rocks. But natural forces cannot create things with specified
complexity, such as Petra. When we see something as intricate as
an ancient city of Petra, we know that the best explanation is that it is the result
of an intelligent designer.
This is how many scientific fields operate.
Take forensic science, for example.
When a forensic scientist comes across a body, he or she asks two general questions.
Is it the result of natural causes, such as a heart attack?
Or is it the result of intelligent activity, homicide?
And the forensic scientist will look for signs of specified complexity to come to
the most reasonable explanation.
Archaeologists do the same thing.
When an archaeologist comes across some kind of ancient relic, he or she asks
themselves, is this the result of natural forces?
Or is it the result
of design? So they will look at the physical features of, say, a
rock that they find. And if they find specified complexity, such as you would see on
an arrowhead, then the archaeologist will conclude that the best explanation is that
this is the result of intelligent design.
And amazingly, we find the same patterns of design in nature itself.
Just take the human body. In the human body, in every single cell, we find DNA.
And in DNA, as we have seen, we have both specificity and complexity.
In fact, there is more information in DNA than in anything humans are close
to creating. The best explanation for DNA is that it was designed by a creator
of life. There are many other examples of design, such as we see in the Cambrian
explosion, in irreducibly complex systems, and even in the origin of the universe
itself.
This is why one of the most common objections against intelligent design fails.
You maybe have heard people say well you're just making an argument from the gaps
it's called the God of the gaps and the idea is we look at nature we don't have a
natural explanation and so we assume God.
But that's not what we're doing we're not looking at nature saying well we lack an
explanation for DNA or we lack an explanation for fine-tuning therefore God did it.
We're essentially saying two things we're saying number one nature can't explain it
alone but we see the positive evidence of an intelligent agent we look at DNA
we see specified complexity we look at the fine-tuning of the laws of physics we see
specified complexity and as we have seen when we see that marker we know the best
explanation is that it is the result of an intelligent designer.
Both naturalism and pantheism fail to adequately explain design in nature for
one basic reason they lack an intelligent agent a cosmic mind
that can produce specified complexity.
In fact they have to rely entirely upon chance time and the laws of nature
but this is like trying to rely upon wind erosion water and other natural
forces to explain the ancient city of Petra.
The most reasonable explanation for design in nature is that the world was actually
designed. That's right design in nature points towards a
designer. This of course should come as no surprise to those of us who believe in
God.
After all long before the discoveries of modern science the psalmist wrote that the
heavens declare the glory of God the skies proclaim His Majesty.
Day by day they spew forth speech night by night they display knowledge.
In other words the psalmist knew that the natural world reveals truths about the
Creator. If the world really is designed if the natural
world is actually filled with specified complexity then this raises a very
important question. Who is this designer?